today we're going to talk about Forks
and we're going to talk about
sacrificing material to get a fork we
have a special guest today who's not
here that's why he's special and his
name is Arjun you've never heard of him
man there was very little complaining
but people at home were like I have
alright and I played Arjun and I played
sort of crazy and then I sacrificed all
my pieces and then his King wasn't so
good one thing I want to talk about
today especially we're talking about
forks is you need your pieces to move
out you can't move the same piece ten
times in a row your other pieces will be
mad at you they all file a lawsuit right
okay so this is my game with Arjun that
was played twenty minutes ago okay so we
played my favourite Traxler variation
most grandmasters play bishop here
because they're chicken you know why
because you are what you eat and they
eat chicken you know what I don't play
that I don't eat chicken I'm a
vegetarian
I play Knight f6 okay I'm not afraid of
Knight g5 I double dared him to play
Knight g5 do they speak English and what
so he played Knight to g5 attacking my F
pawn okay now I could give a one-hour
lecture about this do you know why
because I get paid by the hour
nothing that's still that's still more
laughs than usual okay now when I'm
going to chess tournament
the most common move in this position is
the worst most kids play h6 okay now
when white played Knight to g5 White's
idea of like push the wrong button so I
guess you didn't do it
white wants to play Knight takes f7 so
forcing your opponent to do so is a
little crazy now nine out of ten
grandmasters play d5 here question.what
oh okay and again some of those
grandmasters aren't vegetarians so
that's sort of a chicken move d5 okay
now the most common variation in
children's games is the fried liver why
don't I play that come on I give you the
answer away the whole class I'm a
vegetarian Fido fried liver now the
fried liver unfortunately is Knight
takes pawn Knight takes pawn although no
Grandmaster would play this move they
would play Knight a5 which is not the
fried liver
although most kids think this is the
fried liver okay
terrible okay you know what else is
terrible fried liver terrible okay now I
played whoa oh no this empty plastic
bottle might fall okay now I play Bishop
to c5 sacrificing everything and my
opponents are like oh boy a free
everything and they play Knight takes f7
notice how it's attacking my queen in my
rook so I resigned an argent one is that
what happened now okay so instead I
played the book move Bishop takes f2
check now I have this position yesterday
and my opponent took or he played Kiki
to my opponent's hook
I played Knight takes pawn check and
then I played Queen h4 and he played
Queen f3 and I want a really crazy game
now
White has more material but White's King
is on e3 is that where you want your
king no okay
now origin didn't take my bishop Arjun
play King f1 okay now my Queens attack
so I moved it and then arjan's like
thanks for the rook he's very polite and
now I forgot everything why did I forget
everything no because I'm old I can't
remember theory I looked at this 25
years ago okay 25 years ago you kids
didn't know this position either so you
can't blame me right okay so you 25 yet
so you know the position okay so I play
Queen c5 probably a bad move but I don't
know now I'm defending my bishop and I'm
attacking his bishop so he played d3 and
I play d5 and he was like thank you and
I played Bishop to g4 now unlike some of
you I have all of my pieces out okay his
Queen side not not so developed a little
bit but not much and his King is on f1
so he can't castle and his rook is
trapped you know why my rook is
entrapped do you know why because he
took my rook yeah okay so White's up a
rook but I can Castle queenside he can't
castle I have all my pieces out he has
none of his pieces out so unclear
position probably computer with like
white but what are you guys computers or
humans anyone human human what okay so
Arjen didn't want to lose his Queen so
he played Queen to d2 not only now
here's something you guys might do wrong
maybe when you attack somebody's piece
then they move it away you're like well
they moved it away but maybe where they
moved it as attacking one of your pieces
and that's what he did because arjen's
mean he's attacking my bishop so I move
I fish
away solid ok now Arjun played a move
I'm probably not the best I don't know
he played g3 is that right okay and then
I took your bishop and now Arjun can
take my knight or my bishop now let's
analyze the situation white is up a lot
of material but White's pieces are all
in the back row and on my back row and
his queen is blocking his bishop and he
can't castle all of black's pieces are
great okay
that's called a sacrifice you give some
pieces or pawns away but you checkmate
your opponent and checkmate has what
vitamin vitamin C for checkmate
now Origen didn't know which piece to
take so he started crying and then he
decided the two bishops are important he
took this bishop okay and then my
Knights attacked because my Knights
attacked
so I played Knight f4 now Arjun played
the strangest move I've ever seen okay
that's why he lost Arjun was letting me
win so I could give a lecture on the
game thank you okay
this move is so strange I'll bet you
Arjun doesn't remember what he played do
you remember yeah see I was right
okay now in chess you should develop
your pieces castle and play in the
center is that what he did he played
King he won he wants to castle later yes
who came near him white or black right
but instead I put my knight in the
center now if I was white I wouldn't be
worried about this move and I wouldn't
be worried about this move on the other
hand I might be worried about both now
he played a funny move I like this move
this was hilarious
you have a good sense of humor what
should white do to stop all my knight
forks this class is about forks if you
don't know what they are you can go to
the dining hall they've got a lot of
forks you what is
sergeant's raising his hand you also
weren't you watching this game we know
well you're the innocent test were you
losing to my camera during this game the
answer is now you were beating my comer
than you hyung matin one what's the
answer no you didn't resign you unit you
you never resigned it does stop the
night for yeah what's that
kingi one that gets the prize for the
most illegal move because I have a
bishop on g4 does somebody have a prize
you unknown person yeah what's that
very close see now if we go back in the
game his King was on f1 he went here and
now he went back to f1 that was funny I
thought okay now most of you like to
take pieces some of you don't you'll
like this lecture up Hall because this
game was played since the last lecture
it sure it's true yeah okay now most of
you be like oh boy a free rook look at
me I'm the best
right okay you guys all have funny
voices for some reason now I prefer
vitamin C check me and when I check wing
my opponent I use as many pieces as
possible right if I'm beating up you
little kids you might beat me up so I
get three or four of my friends to help
right then if you're like a
five-year-old and there's like six
adults we can take you unless you run
away then we give up yes I got more
pieces into the attack Knight f3 I have
so many pieces near his King that's very
confusing now I have two threats one
threat you see and one threat you don't
see you see Knight takes Queen what's
the threat you don't see how can you
raise your hand if you don't see it what
when Arjun is raising is in
that's correct but I have a follow-up
question do you do your own stunts look
at your shirt alright this so he played
Queen to f2 and I traded Queens right
because you want to trade Queens when
your checkmating somebody now I play the
other threat Bishop h3 if you're under
the age of five you have to leave now
because you can't see this too young
what can I help you yes yeah I have a
question for you do you see your king is
in check
uh oh okay now most of you would think
it's checkmate and shake hands but Arjun
is really good he played the best move
Arjun
Queen g2x clam and then check me in real
life and in chess you don't want to walk
into a fork ow
I don't know which is worse right hey
the kids some of the kids got dad all
right now I want to show you something
that happens a lot so I can yell at all
of you I haven't yelled at children in
like an hour I'm getting rusty over here
alright now when I watch children play
every game goes like this and then I
start crying I don't even need to look
at their notation sheet okay every game
starts like this raise your hand if
you've had this position before
come on tell the truth yeah yeah well
that's better okay now in this position
I tell my students who have the black
pieces to make a very sneaky move and
then some of the make sure remember most
of them don't okay and this is called
the equalizing fork trick okay no no you
don't jump up and down with a fork you
can hurt somebody have a seat
hey how come last class you were jumping
up and down now they are what happened
did you transfer all your energy hi
Arjun two things what's that a pseudo
sacrifice and 984
okay so 94 is correct now there's a
little caveat and the reason is caveat
to your favorite word right good job
this would have also been good yeah
they're very good okay
now the caveat is if black has a Bishop
on c5 this trick doesn't work if your
Bishop is on c5 don't do this I've
actually seen kids do it is pretty funny
now the idea is white says thank you for
the free night and now black does his
favorite fork come on people with the
people at home were like screaming at
their television the d5 okay now black
sacrificed to peace but he's going to
get it back because he's going to win
one of these pieces I have this position
a lot most of my opponents play here
here material is equal but look at my
bishops
they have lots of places to go okay
don't get hit by a train that's why we
put that there
man class is slower than usual yeah it's
like a holiday or something okay and and
you should go because it's green all
right and then if you don't want to go
then you do this right I mean I couldn't
make red arrows terrible joke okay now
I've seen some kids play Bishop c5 which
is okay
Castle then they do the same sacrifice
this doesn't work because after this
well now your bishop is hanging thank
you for the bishop and you get this
bishop but if you're good at counting
white is up an extra piece white has two
knights and black has one night so when
the bishops on c5 you can't play this
forked wreck
this trick works all the time I'll show
you another example I can show you a lot
of examples in this position all the
nights are out everybody's happy
okay now if super grandmasters are
playing they play Bishop to b4 however I
used to play this with white before you
were born
and before you were born but not before
you were born no you but now you yeah I
used to play this with white and most of
my opponents would play here
now what did I do that I just taught you
I taught you one minute ago says a long
time ago
you've played seven video games in the
interim Martin what's the answer
what is why you do it's very tricky what
is it yeah you're right
what yeah I take then they take and then
I go here yeah
and I attack their pieces and also if
they defend their Knight I don't take
their night I go here then they're so
confused okay now look at the white
bishops they have millions of squares to
move to also known as 12 or so and
blacks Bishop can't move at all and
White has all the pawns in the center
and black loses all of his pieces of the
center so that's a good move most of my
opponents make a mistake here and they
sacrifice their bishop
so my King doesn't move my king can't
castle what do you think of white Center
good Center I have two bishops a good
Center good for whyatt computer would
love Wyatt
so actually Bishop c5 is not a good move
because of the fork trick
another fork trick which I see all the
time in kids games is they develop their
pieces too much then a pawn Forks their
pieces and they cry okay when you get
hit by a fork it's natural to cry right
okay that's why when you get fro you'll
use a spoon right raise your hand if
you've gotten Froyo before raise your
hand if you're getting Froyo today after
class he's like wait a minute has a good
idea
did you know Froyo is like hmm where
should we have a Froyo store whoo next
to the Chess Club that's a good idea is
that what happened
yeah maybe what do I know okay now I'm
going to show you these four tricks that
people are falling into but you guys
would never fall into them right never
never okay in this position which I've
seen before a lot of kids play Bishop e6
yay all my pieces are out it's good to
put all your pieces out unless your
opponent captures them that's not so
good and now you're walking into a fork
is there a prop I can show an example
there's not good anyone anyone d4c you
were so close
d4 attacks the bishop because I said so
the bishop moves away maybe
and now d5 and black cries because black
played Bishop e6 walking into a fork so
bishop not good on e6 dish up anywhere
but II 6 or f5 or h3 Bishop g4 is good
Bishop d7 is good castling is good if
you have a bishop here and a knight here
that means a pawn here will fork them so
you have to watch out for that and be
careful if you put your pieces on
certain squares
you don't want pawns to fork them now
I'm going to tell you a secret don't
tell the people at home on the internet
don't tell them they won't be able to
hear this because of magic okay you're
going to hear what they want okay
actually we could make that happen yeah
that could make that happen yeah okay
you
so in this position if you have a night
on a dark Square and a bishop on a white
square a pawn can't afford them a knight
can't afford them and a bishop can't
afford them but when you but when you
play Bishop e6 and they're both on white
squares that means a pawn could fork
them or a knight or a bishop the best
thing to fork with is a pawn because
when you fork two pieces or three pieces
and you lose your pawn you're going to
get something better if you fork with a
queen and you lose your queen that fork
didn't work very well that was the worst
ever
yeah there's no humming in class wait
this is all wrong everything I did was
wrong
okay now I'm great let's look at this
position so that the class is less
confused okay this is a fork it's the
worst fork ever if you get this fork you
should ask for your server and get a new
fork this fork won't work at all
okay so this Queen is attacking this
pawn and it's attacking this pawn but
you don't want to take either pawn
because you'll lose your queen
so Queens forking pawns not too good
pawn forking a king and queen very good
right so you want to take little pieces
ones that you can't see and fork big
pieces ones that you need help carrying
like the ones across the street are
those big pieces right we know like for
example some people eat dinner and some
people go across the street and play
chess during dinner who would that be
she's looking all innocent there I don't
know guilty yes you're not guilty you're
innocent so here this doesn't work if if
white takes this pawn that's terrible
for white and if white takes this pawn
that's terrible for white that's not a
good Fork a good fork is when your pawn
is forking big pieces okay and every
piece is bigger than a pawn so that
works out well not
all Forks are good now I'm going to show
you another trick that's based on a fork
pretty cool trick nobody knows it been
me and because I used to be a kid and
tricks are for kids night here on a pond
tanks and then efore and that Bishop III
and now white wants to take the pawn and
say yummy yummy yummy yummy and black
says no I'll defend my pawn haha well
I've seen worse come on I saw you guys
play upstairs earlier come on okay
now White has an amazing move that will
shock all of you you have to be at least
three to sit in class
what's the shocking move that's shocking
exactly shocking means you're very
surprised okay you see how the knight
defended the pawn wouldn't it surprise
you if white took it with that surprise
you that's surprise yeah but that moves
okay so black plays the obvious move and
now this class is about Forks so what
does white do this class is about forks
Oh have a seat bathrooms over there yeah
no not you at home to sit down yeah I
don't jump off your couch come on anyone
yes you can go to the bathroom but you
have to pay no no it's free to it's a
holiday it's a holiday it's free okay
yes yeah
Queen a4 check the Queen attacks the
king and the Queen attacks the knight
white gets his knight back now before we
do class dismissed which is the best
part of class we're going to show two
funny examples of people doing that
trick to me but it didn't work so they
lost then what did they do
they cried okay now don't blink because
the first game in is really fast my
opponent was
rated 1950 whoo right okay yeah okay and
I was black and remember that trick I
just showed you my opponents like hey
I'm gonna do that trick now he must have
gone into the future and saw this class
that went back to the game he took my
pawn I took his Knight what did he do
queen a4 and now I made a move he didn't
see and he cried always incorrect you
Queen to d2 I did not see fam
double-check yeah but look how awesome
it is I assumed he meant Queen to d7
again but White's threatening this
Bishop and whites threatening the king
so what did black do to save them both
aren't you never see it you oh sorry
here right now that's okay but then
White's going to play Queen takes bishop
you don't want white supply Queen zigs
bishop hey you guys took the exact same
time no you both get the gold medal yes
no the one who does his own stunts I
nobody else in the class through that
especially Arjen fauna b5 and my
opponent resigned yes is that what you
would do he's the worst right he's down
he's down a piece he's out a knight
okay now I'm from Ann Arbor Michigan he
didn't know that he would lose his
knight but I know about working on my
Knight moves cuz I'm for me Ann Arbor
right no no Bob Seger fans here okay now
the last one which also happened in Ann
Arbor the first one didn't I was white
and we can't flip the board had it and
he played my favorite pizza
Sicilian okay I sacrificed a pond and
he's like now he played in the center
with this move he he has his own sensor
it's not like ours okay
and I said yummy yummy yummy yummy yummy
and he called the director and said my
opponent said yummy yummy yummy yummy
yummy and the director said well yeah he
took upon that's okay
yeah the director was on my side now he
went here to take the pond and I
protected my pond and guess what he did
he took the pond anyway and I took the
bishop and what did he do this guy was
rated 1500 plus tax with no tax taxes
lowered Michigan Martin what did black
do Queen a5 attacking my king and
attacking my bishop and I went to Kokomo
I said Kokomo what's the best move and
What did he say b4 right okay my
opponent did not resign he lost later
right
so des Forks always work no but don't
walk into a fork because that hurts
and now I just called Magnus Carlsen he
just texted me and What did he say
no no What did he say
Magnus just texted me man you kids I
sent you the script last night
Dave you read it terrible you don't know
you hope don't come to class enough to
know yes yeah he would he would have
said that with that accent oh yeah
now Magnus Carlsen said my two favorite
words class dismissed